as I I don't have a real understanding
of where I'll be in five lectures so you
know I have sort of an understanding on
what I will say today so hopefully this
will be an interactive process you know
after all I'm doing it on the board I of
course I have prepared a little bit so
alkalyn said that this would be a boot
camp you know on boot camp or
traditionally I don't know Israeli boot
camp are probably much worse than
Swedish boot camps in the world first
place so you know you're asked the
audience questions and if they give you
the wrong answer they have to do
push-ups right all of them okay so I
decided that when you have an audience
that's you know not forced to go there I
decided to reverse things so I asked the
audience questions and if they they
answered correctly they get chocolates
okay so I've prepared now something
chocolates here so good good answers are
rewarded by chocolates and also you know
when I completely lose to one of the
worst experiences a lecture is that you
sort of at the end of a lecture suddenly
get the question that you thought that
everybody knew in the beginning is sort
of explained it's 30 seconds at the
beginning so these kind of stupid
questions please ask them they're gross
of be rewarded with chocolates way to do
it but it was it was a question that
brought the lecture forward for one
reason why this is theme so it's up to
me okay good so please ask questions
please tell me when I'm saying the wrong
thing so when you can't see what I'm
writing or whatever okay
so a generic constraint satisfaction
problem is cool it's going to be three
set for a while so we have you know
variables somewhere negated and we never
have put numbers I'll have in fact plus
minus one notation as in the
and in boolean cases you know minus one
is true okay yeah and I this isn't you
know I have no man to complete problems
it's hard to find optimal assignment
right it's we don't believe in
polynomial time that we can find the
best assignment but we're gonna talk
about the approximability and then i'm
going to talk about max 3sat
by the way I'll be very bad with you no
motivation and references okay so if you
want to know where something comes from
you can ask me maybe I'll know and yeah
motivation I'll just think that this is
great stuff and you're going to think so
much so I have the end of the lectures
and if you don't that's your problem
okay so we have max 3sat I want to
satisfy as many as possible and since
it's hard to determine if you can
satisfy them all that we won't be able
to solve this perfectly so what will be
interesting is the approximation ratio
and this is if you have some algorithm
and have some polynomial time algorithm
in mind and the ratio will be interested
is the minimum of how well the algorithm
does over the optimum okay that's the
approximation ratio widget and also I'll
be dealing with something here which
I'll call ease 3sat and this is simply
that each Clause is of length exactly
three okay thanks so now I for asked a
first easy question and mostly to answer
can anybody get an approximation ratios
for max reset how do you do it okay
since you're so good that was not a word
you need to do better to get chocolates
okay that's good luck yes what seven or
eight yeah why yes you can do it an
expectation can't do it deterministic
you okay good so
so 7 over 8 okay by random assignment
and candy dear my dear dear randomized
and so she has to repeat this if you
pick these three guys randomly you know
the probability that they're all false
is 1/8 so on on average will satisfy 7/8
of the clauses and the optimum will
never do more than all of them right so
you get 7 8 so the first theorem
so the this theme that I'm going to
spend a good fraction but probably all
of today and some of next time to try to
prove is that it's MP what you do better
you cannot beat 7/8 buy more buy more
than you know for any positive number
you can't do better than 7/8 Plus this
number okay
and
and in fact I've called suggesting
approximation assistant well I saw that
very abusive notation I'll say the 3sat
is approximation resistant because you
can't you can't do better approximation
than what you get by just don't look at
the instance flip random bits and be
happy that's I'm gonna so somehow it's
3sat is an extremely difficult problem
even if I give you something where you
can satisfy all or almost all the
closest that in fact it's hard to do
better than what the random assignment
does so how many have seen the proof of
this theorem okay that's good fraction
how many could do the proof of this
theorem right now well that's an if
somebody raises their hand yeah that's a
that's a good point but yeah so so some
of you might be bored but I'll do that
try to do a lot of the details of this
thing
so it's going to be a very simple idea
so this have say M closest
so the overall idea is extremely simple
we just connect in polynomial time we
get on a formula Phi we're going to
produce a different formula which sumit
has m closest which has the property if
the original form is satisfiable so it's
the second one and if the first one is
not satisfiable so this is of course of
sine not only the result people are not
satisfied what's in fact extremely
strongly non satisfied but that no
assignment can do more than sort of this
expected ratio 7/8 plus epsilon so
you're happy that this this such a
transformation will in fact prove this
theorem because if I don't know how many
people is this one of these well thing
to explain good
so geek and die tell me explaining why
this is enough
so if I know that suppose I could tell
between a satisfiable formula and one
which is not even seven eight plus
epsilon satisfiable then using this
process I could distinguish between fee
which is satisfiable and fee which is
not satisfiable even if it's almost
satisfy but because I would first apply
this transformation and then and then I
would apply this you know whatever
algorithm I have for side to distinguish
good thank you
so the one point that was supposed to
bring up that I didn't
so there are a few things we should get
with one we sort of touched on the
patrician determine once and for all
first of all this approximation
algorithm I sort of gave the ratio we
could ask for two things either the yes
determine the optimum value say that
this is the maximum value of the number
closest the Kami service 5 or I cannot
actually ask to get an assignment that
does this ok clearly it's harder to find
it might be harder to find a good
assignment and actually determine the
value ok so I won't be very explicit on
these things but one thing to observe
here first this argument that guy is
cake do we need to find the assignment
or is it enough to use to determine the
value approximately yes yes yeah yeah
yeah yes you need some external
guarantee that it doesn't yeah if you
don't have a good proof to you know you
could think of all present yeah yeah
good good so yeah we will assume that
the algorithm so we need to add the
constraint always that's that's a
correct that's but it's not free fact to
to to approximate the value that's all I
need further to determine if this
original formula is satisfiable right so
it turns out that almost is almost over
hardness the result is what I promised
it's enough to find the I mean to know
the value but in fact most approximation
algorithms that have will not do in fact
that you'll find a good assignment so
somehow you get the best of these things
you know when you have an algorithm you
actually do the whole thing and the
hardness result trust requires you to do
these using
but I will in general our randomized
algorithm and then I will in fact have
the expectation here but then you should
remember that I will only allow
randomization over the internal choices
of the algorithm I won't have any you
know average case instances here their
worst case instances but randomized
somewhere good
so in fact something once you know that
such a transformation exists generally I
relax you deliver on this eventually you
know there might be a completely
combinatorial way to do this you know if
you gave it to somebody in the in the
80s says please do this it's not maybe
you guys already have some ideas how to
do this so when you space out and stop
listening to me you can you think of
other ways to do this
yes I want to talk lots of the intuition
and lots of the results would be from
verifiers that verified proofs and such
stability you know the first time you
teach that stability said well this can
be efficiently verified you know if you
have a three set formula fire up sign
here you can write down a satisfying
assignment and then you can just verify
it you go over all the clauses and just
check it okay and the point now is that
they look to be about the same in this
but we all know how we verify proofs I
don't know how you verify proofs but if
you get the proof it's sort of at first
attempt you don't read at all and check
all the details but you sort of look at
the interesting point and check that
that checks out right and this is
exactly what we'll do here so I'm sure
if you will get given by hand the
formula with 100 variables and three
thousand closes you wouldn't go through
them all but you would say you know give
write down the satisfying assignment and
then just check around them flows right
and normally that doesn't work too well
because there could be an assignment
assess where all the closes except one
but note that that's an extremely good
proof for sigh only already in a formal
way
this is sort of an important points
let's see I have I am so lets the
claimants want to be making let's think
of it as the claim that the original
formula five satisfiable okay and we
sort of think as you as extremely lazy
verifiers so you're not willing to read
very much so in fact you only want to
read three bits we sort of correspond
store closer sort of picking random
clothes and checking it so my point is
now that's much better to read the
random clothes from five I'm sorry from
size and to read one from five because
if you read something random from fire
you don't have any really guarantees but
if you read the random clothes from
beside you in fact you have almost an
eighth probability of catching it
somebody's like right because we know if
the Regional Forum was not satisfiable
and the assignment would falsify almost
an eighth full of the clauses so you can
be very efficient so this is really a
remarkable statement right so this is
saying that you know you can check if
you have a formula Phi with the million
variables and then you translate it
efficient it's I and then you can check
it by just reading three bits everybody
happy with this
oh yeah so well I'll do them so what the
thing we'll need so the claim is that
what we have back to construct implies
incredibly efficient proof system and
we'll actually need to start with a very
efficient proof system in that with the
the PCP theorem by Aaron Luna Madonna
stood on the Sega tee
so the PCP theorem says that you can
fake any you know 3sat formula where a
and P statement product is and have a
polynomial size proof that's it check by
verifying the flips order log and random
points reads only constant number of
bits and rejects any proof or an
incorrect statement with probability
that's independent on the size of the
proof how many people saw the piece of
piece fear before how many did not see
it that's okay so you will almost all
have seen it and you sort of believe it
and see it's a fantastic theorem right
how many agree that this is apart from
this constant seven eight agree that
this is more or less that these two
statements are essentially the same who
needs to be convinced of this nobody
needs to be good you should be prepared
you know what
yeah but let me let me let me let's let
me stick yeah so you can say that you
can redefine the PCP theorem to say this
with a different constant here right but
then you you then you you're sort of
cheating right because then you've
already established whatever we're going
to do now on this board so so but
there's a pedagogical point also
I don't out of prompt
so then the the personality constants
they have in mind when we're talking
about this is the unscrupulous prove er
so what does the unscrupulous prover
want well he just wants to convince the
verifier he doesn't care if a formula is
satisfiable he just wants to maximize
the probability that the verifier
accepts he doesn't he doesn't even look
at the formula just knows what the
verifier is going to do and just try to
make the verifier happen as some
students do right they don't do their
homework they as the want to convince
their professors like also some
researchers do just you just want to
please the referees and they don't care
of their theorems are true so what's the
problem what problems are sound
scrupulous very unscrupulous prove your
face okay well it sort of looks at the
verifier whatever this might be in the
PCP theorem and then is sort of the
verifier would have some random coins we
have to verify just have series of
random coins
out
the verifier will do something suppose
just to make life a little bit simpler
that this let's pretend that this number
is three to make it look even little bit
more so he knows that if the verified
random coins are all zeros that in fact
is going to look and fit seventeen bit
23 and bit 48 of the proof and check
that they're not all minus ones why does
this is beyond him but that's what he
can read up to the verifies program
after all the verifier is just a program
right well she verifies coins are zero
zero zero one he'll read some other bit
you know bit 18 bit 27 not just a bad
random number generator and then it
maybe check that they're they're not old
ones and finally when the verified coins
or old ones he'll read some other 3ds
but
if you just tried to tell what's going
on
well what this does is sort of we'll
think of these bits of the proof as
variables and he let's just write down
this condition saying that well it might
be that one of these three bits are
false remember that minus one is true
and Hilary write down that I don't know
what this is but nevermind north or
minus one it means that they shouldn't
all be true which means at least one of
them should be false I think I got it
right but then it's the principle that
matters anyhow yeah and the point is
that you know if stick the case does but
whatever it whatever this is yeah but
with everything so then the next step up
is to say well suppose he's doesn't have
such a simple and now you see that if
this is the case I mean if conditions
are like this I exactly have a 3sat
formula right this is the first Clause
this is the first Clause the probability
that the verifier accepts on their
particular proof which is just an
assignment to all the bits is exactly so
we're trying to optimize this thing and
the next thing to say is well it might
not be such a nice that it's a clause
maybe this is another formula of a three
in a formula but then you just put the
formula there and take the conjunction
if you reads more than three bits you
take a little bit better than you have
to apply the transformation but it's
really if you think about the
unscrupulous prover how he convinces to
verify it's really working out dumb all
these formulas that's reasonably okay
now you don't that you don't get 7/8
okay so this is here you get some some
constant that depends on CA where CA is
this number right so now to get the 7/8
we have to start doing work
let's
and
but this is where we're going and this I
won't prove this is a long and
complicated proof and I want to adult
assume that this theorem is proved it
there was an original proof by these
guys in this a new proof by the noir and
this is how I recommend it if you want
to read whether this is will take me a
couple of lectures just to prove this I
I won't promise
nothing to do present technology from
scratch yeah so it doesn't take a
semester I mean II reach proof is
probably simpler probably less if the
good audience
so that's
for this thing we get so far from the
PCP theorem is nearly what we want you
know massaging things with this is a
three set formula this is a three set
formula and it has this property that we
preserve such stability and then the
best assignments we get some some ratios
CA where this is just a constant smaller
than seven eighths and the first proof
will really give a the constant here
that's extremely close to one so the
name of the game now is to improve this
constant
so the next thing I want to do is to
make a talk over again
so the two-player game I want is that we
start with this you know this end result
to the PCP theorem and the verifier will
pick a random close and look at the
random variable from this
this
but there might be you know there might
be negation zero song the guys
I am so in he sensed their identity of
the close to p1 is sense identity of a
variable to p2 and then it gets values
for all the three variables in the
clause from p1 and from one of the
values of p2 and what one wants to check
is that CJ satisfied and X I
consistently so notice it gets values
for all the three variables in the
clause and two values for one of the
variables any check the doors agree
we're happy with this so what's the
optimal stress so if the formula
satisfied with this and strategy for p1
and p2 that always makes the verifier
accept right they just agree on a
satisfying assignment and they tell the
verify this what's the optimal strategy
if you can only satisfy a fraction CA of
the closest how well can they convince
the verified yeah that's the intuitive
thing is that the best I can do yeah
that's a good question they can be
random of course it does it pay for p1
and p2 to be random why not
yeah there's always an optimal
deterministic strategy in these games
you know everything is known the formula
is known the verify strategy is known so
if you if you noticed
let's fix any possibly probabilistic
strategy for p1 and then say when he
gets a close but well p2 gets a variable
you can sort of see which closest goes
with this one and it picked the
deterministically best strategy for
himself so you can make him
deterministic and it's easy to see that
you then you can make p1 deterministic
so what's the best strategy but most P 2
is deterministic is just an assignment
right
and once you fix p2 to an assignment you
can well we can look at p1 and says when
the name of the assignment of p2
satisfies CJ we'll just answer according
to it when money doesn't will flip one
of the variables
so except in the very few cases when the
therefore blessed when the salmon
doesn't satisfies the Claus will happens
with probably the CA than Allah
they'll always win and when it doesn't
they lose with the probability 1/3
because the check in question will
actually agree with where p2 cheated
everybody happy with this one yes so we
okay with our deterministic p1 and p2 so
p2 gets an assignment right then he
turns into an assignment because he has
gets identity our variable in there
returns the value so whenever it and
most of the time it that assignment will
sell they fix this to be the best
assignment which will satisfy a fraction
CA of the clauses so whenever the clause
is satisfied p1 will answer accordingly
in a voice with but when it doesn't
satisfy the clause p1 will cheat on one
of the three variables and they'll be
caught with a probability 1/3 okay
thanks so when I did do bad explanations
well you can being put there's a lecture
tomorrow you know you want to pass for
this yeah my perfect answer
good so this it's good remaining it to
prove again we moved a little bit closer
to one and not too much but a little bit
which is not good and now come the
second greatest statement I need
so what's the cherry parallel game well
we just have the standard game we now
just repeated K times so we pick the
verifier picks K losses if it's one
random variable in each clause this
sense the closest to one guy and and the
variables to the other and then it gets
back assignments and you just want to
see that is the assignments are
satisfying the satisfy all the closest
and they're consistent you know gets the
same value for all of this
and what you might hope if you haven't
seen it before is that the optimum
strategy for p1 and p2 would sort of go
down as a exponentially the number of
repetitions after what we have to kill
games so unfortunately to proper games
are fairly complicated so it doesn't go
down with this exponent as Ron Russ
proved a long time ago it does go down
exponentially with K but possibly with a
different exponent and this is the
parallel repetition here
and this the proof of this was
originally very complicated and in a
horrible code
sorry wrong it wasn't a lot of fun to
read but it was a great progress in it
was open for a number of years to prove
the pattern repetition theorem the proof
has gotten simpler and the constants
have gotten better but also proving this
parallel repetition theorem would be
yellin all to lectures these days it's a
general statement about ten parallel
repetition of to prover games you know
big exponent goes down that the
acceptance goes down with the number of
copies cuz now's exponentially but the
constant might surprise you any
questions but to prove against how I
came to this conclusion
now I wanted to have an abstract game
which I'll call labor cover which will
have two kinds of vertices one to the
left and one to the right it will have
some edges for each edge I will have a
projection and a solution that this
label covers to label each vertex and
footage for the guys to the left I'll
have a small label and for the guys to
the right I'll have which it will be
from assets you know capital S in size
the latest hood to the right will have a
label from s at L which is the large and
the way to check such a label cover
instance is that you know you pick a
random edge read the two labels and and
look at the corresponding projection see
if the projection is correct so now I
see if I can move too quickly so what
does this have to do with the to prove
your games
yes yeah good your photos chocolate hmm
yeah you want her lover it yeah yeah so
these guys to the left story you know
pop and some variables right that's a
lot of a question with the tough love
variables the things to the right maybe
I should have this chocolate back you
know yeah possibly 7 to the K yeah
because they we're baby I didn't discuss
this but some up P one should always
return except the things that are
accepted by it it doesn't make sense for
him to return things that don't sell
tried it the close right then the point
is that this these projections are just
thinking that we have this you know
you're happy with this the things these
are assignments variables and closes to
variables it closes
these are assignment to do share
variables
- as in cake noises and these
projections are you know take the
coordinates sent to the guy
all right
yeah yeah yeah yes
sorry sir yeah so they're the names and
the labels are the assignments yeah
you're right thanks
so in fact if you be abstracting it away
it says you know if the regional
formulas that we started with a long
time ago namely this formula if this was
satisfiable but then we had something
then once and this was satisfiable that
we have perfect completeness in there in
the basic to prove a game that we had
you know perfect completeness in the
repeated to prove our game and that
leaves a labeling that satisfies all the
edges right or the other hand if we
started with the written with something
was not satisfiable then we did see a
therefore fine and then within the
parallel repetition this went down with
like exponential in K and if you just
change parameters you only slightly this
means that the best aside labeling which
is an a strategy for the to prove s
belong satisfy a fraction epsilon orbit
of the two if you pick a large enough
and in fact this the sets of the labels
will grow with epsilon but only
polynomially launch right this was like
you know C prime to the K and these four
other things to the K so they're
exponentially in epsilon to start with
so claim knowledge corollary tell me
hard to distinguish label cover
instances where you can satisfy all the
constraints the label covers instance
which can only satisfy an epsilon
fraction of the constraints and this
just follows by this you know
unscrupulous prover sort of argument it
I mean the unskillful approver that
tries to convince a verifier sort of
tries to satisfy as many as possible and
if you can figure out the optimal ratio
that in fact we can distinguish these
two cases and you can determine if the
original formula fiber satisfiable or
not okay so do you get this for non
constant Epsilon
like I say I saying for any constant
epsilon here I'm not asking if it's true
for no one constant epsilon is just
saying that you know does this proof
work for non constant epsilon yes the
alphabet size depends on epsilon as
universal polynomial in Epsilon yes the
problem is if epsilon is sub constant
and K is super constant and the number
of things here is like m to the K right
because Jeff and this side is like m to
the K and then M more open so if you
want this to be a polynomial time
reduction we want these numbers to be
polynomial and that's why I can only do
this for constant scale but we can
return this it turns out that you can
actually get long constant KS got known
constant epsilon but but then you have
to redo everything and you can't just
rely on tell the repetition and this are
not going to do so thank you good but
now now we're starting to close in on
our are we sort of be made progress
right we now make progress that in fact
we're in a situation where it really
sort of we should think of these
labelings as proofs and the properties
when you're trying to prove true
statements all checks will work out and
when we try when some when desperately
unscrupulous prove is trying to prove
full statement it can only satisfy very
few of their constraints right that's
why we're in such a good situation but
the problem is that these labels are big
and we'll have to make them smaller
again you guys want to break by the way
I'm sort of I get sort of warm I usually
just talk for 45 minutes now or an hour
but I'll try to talk for another so
let's see what what we're going to do
so the thing we I all of you think we've
done so far is we're gonna have because
remember this label cover we're going to
remember that it's hard to distinguish
the case when we can satisfy all the
vertices sorry
satisfy all the edges American only
satisfy very small fraction and now we
want sort of to build on this
it's maybe retreat
so this is the theorem I promised you I
don't think I'll get to that today but
then I'll start proving this theorem and
we'll see how far we get and I have to
define the problems involved
so max realistic will be the system of
equations where monomials of degree 3 is
equal to constants why do I call such a
nonlinear system max 3 Lin yes you think
a little bit more love yeah this is just
parity questions right so that's why
it's a linear it's just so if you can
satisfy all equations of this type what
happens then
all right Tennessee asleep these are
linear equations like this and you know
their bits and you answer once and you
add them and it's linear algebra and you
saw them in polynomial time
okay so if you have M equations here
oh well I'm not giving this away but and
so we should do so how do you well can
you do this if you want to know I sort
of you should be able to do a half right
so what's the easy argument you can do a
half here and yeah yeah that's that
works that's another way to do it
one zero so which one's yeah just a
random one also works but old series and
old ones but that's not us and then a
random one and that's equally well so on
but the question can do better so
so what we're really trying to prove
again is that this predicate is also
approximation resistant that you can't
do better I mean from an approximation
ratio point of view you can't do better
than picking a random assignment that's
what we want to do and then we'll see
how this implies what we happen but
and then we gonna use that an idea that
was around for a while and it's we want
the cold sort of the labels
thank you was her just curious how is
especially how bad can be would you get
the system how bad so now you want sort
of well you can make up to them exactly
half right the way I set up things you
can just have two equations which are
generally chatters negations without
cheating
em I can probably make it then you can
take take and and with three yeah maybe
you it's square root on them square root
M yes you can always worry but now
you're always gets you know aggressive
form or how can you make this a function
of it and the name and so forth sorry I
got side so now I gotta code this these
assignments and and what I'm going to do
is I'm going to use something called the
long coat which was enthused by bigger
bar called Rajan Sudan which plays an
enormous role in this field Edison
one way to view it is to tell I'll have
some label in some set and I'll use the
exponential many bits in this and I'll
think of these bits as a function so it
takes inputs which are minus 1 1 to this
and simply what a correct long code of
the as the label lambda you should
believe that you return this this
coordinate so it's a dictatorship
function
Oh
so the way we're going to do this is
that for each vertex here which should
really contain a label we'll make it a
truth table of a function which should
be the long in a correct proof of a
correct statement it should be the long
code of the corresponding label
sometimes I call this the standard
written proof because it was used so
many times
we want to replace it there about my
exponentially many bits and it should be
the long code of the corresponding labor
in the correct proof of a correct
statement it should simply be the long
code we find the long code over there
and the name of the game now is to check
this standard written proof I cleverly
asking questions in it yeah so always
when you're looking at polynomial time
reductions you should always be wary of
Exponential's
so are we aware of you're afraid of
these Exponential's are we afraid
yeah SNL our you know constants that
depend on the outside oil so there you
know in practice of course this which we
would never be able to represent these
proofs with the number of atoms in the
universe but it's a constant so that's
we're happy
so the way we're going to do it now it
to make cleverly checkable proof if that
will pick a random entry and then we
have a little table sitting here we're
and table sitting there this will be my
fu this is my G W and we're going to
read some bits in them
so this Vanna Sonya random I'm in
uniform and so forth
so pick one random point here which is X
I'll pick Ram random point there which
is wife and then I'll cleverly
constructed Third Point Z which is sort
of the product which is actually the XOR
of these two guys almost all the time
when maybe let me let me
and then I'll check that the bit that
the z-position is actually the product
of the bit of the white position and the
exposition is everybody happy with this
sorry
but now I'm guessing reading three bits
right that's you know we have these
constructive this utopia can now just
reading to a bit
so now likely that if you fact have a
correct standard written proof and no I
mean it sort of implies I'm sort of you
just repeating this that's you know we
had the true statement to start with you
know we had the perfect strategy in the
to prover game where the perfect
strategy and the repeated to prove our
game we correctly coded the labels then
in fact I claim that we accept that this
test is going to accept with probability
1 minus death that will Delta is exactly
this number so now we're just and this
is not a difficult statement this is
just trying to understand all the things
we've put together so some of you look a
little bit tired so who sees that this
is true that's too few you have to do
push-ups I'm just going to give you
chocolates for this one okay so let's
make a question why should you do like
this fashion job to in the small and one
in the big guns
yeah but we can talk about that tomorrow
I think we can talk about that tomorrow
it's just check check how these things
are okay so let's try to unravel this
statement for your head so what do I
mean by it by it a correct standard
written proof well at each point here
sits a label right this guy has a label
lambda U and this have a label lambda W
and we have the property
that the project did I raced is that the
projection of lambda W is equal to
lambda V right that's that's exactly
what it says that we have that's on the
label cobble level the fact we have you
have this label covering thing we have
the projections and when we have these
good labeling such that respecting these
projections now that they have correct
long codes of things let's look at this
very bit we're trying to read there well
we have this table F you and if you have
a correct loan cuz of a correct thing
this should be the corresponding
coordinate of X given by this label
right
in the same way that the guys we're
reading over here that jeez we're
reading the y&z points over here well in
a correct it's correctly coded thing
this guy will be the young the
corresponding coordinates in the bigger
table
and then we go back how these things
were coded when we see that the Z
variable we just defined to be the wife
most of the time we probably 1 minus
Delta it's the corresponding wine
variable constant times X at the
projection
this is with probability 1 minus Delta
and this is exactly so it repeals 1
minus Delta with the correct coding
we've just you know set up things so
they're actually perfectly aligned
you're happy with this and maybe we'll
do it again just to punish you on the
tomorrow
so let's call this else
okay so now the the important soundness
lemma that well we'll see what we're
going to do is that suppose first we can
say well this is just checking the
identity you don't even erase this no
we're just checking whether two bits are
equal so we can only hope to have some
that's like a half here but I said say
that if they have a proof but that makes
the verifier of this protocol except
with a hat it's like a more probability
that in fact we can extract the labeling
that makes that sort of satisfy a good
fraction of the edges in the label cover
okay and if I have this lemma that's the
end of the the proof of a proxy like 3
lid ok I bought I won't be insulted but
these are the claim is that now we're
essentially done
ok so let's so we need the completeness
you know the fact that because a good
proof that except with good probability
was very simple the soundness level will
be moderately difficult once you have
the set up the machinery it's not very
difficult to prove but we'll prove it
next time I think so the only thing I
want to do now is sort of by louder and
louder voice try to say that this
finishes the proof ok does anybody want
to explain why this what we want to
prove
what did do I claim that we proved
ah I like cheated your multitec so sorry
sorry sorry I cheated you in one detail
thus anybody can come up with the proof
if you're sort of a you didn't follow it
all now okay and you just want to make
this stupid verify except how do you
make him accept say $1 grace sorry but
the person in front of you right you can
say one novice you see this if you're
always you know if you complete all this
table by ones we're just checking that
the one bit is equal to the product of
two other [ __ ] okay so we need dance
like to be taller
so I'm not going to be the when I use my
long terms I want to enforce the the
property that if you negate all the
inputs in fact and the answers is
negated and this would be called folding
and the way I'm going to do it is that
for each pair X and minus X I'll just
store one bit in the table and by
conventional say it's the first guy in
the pair and when I read what I now want
to read Z I have to take a look at its
pair and if it's Perry if it's the first
in its peril use that bit and if it's
not the first in the para I'll use the
negation of that bit son make sure that
we this sort destroys this strategy of
only acid putting once because only the
second house will ask things in the
second half you get the minus
so the thing I claimed that I more or
less given you the best part of the
proof of is the descent power to
distinguish instances or max real in
where you can satisfy 1 minus Delta
fraction from the case where you can
only satisfy half plus Delta prime
fraction and why is this so
right so the way to think about this I
can't write if you think about the
unscrupulous prover in this systems you
know when we didn't believe you coded
everything by the long code and the
unscrupulous provably sort of thinking
how to complete these tables I claim
what he's looking at is exactly a max
real in max thrillin instance right he
wants to go over all the verifier coin
speaking all these things and knows that
in the end the verifier is going to read
three of these pits and he's gonna check
in an equation of these that via the
folding might turn out that is the
product of these three it should be one
or the product of these three bits
should be minus one right now you're not
not being as you're supposed to I can
hold you here for another but not that
many minutes but step who is it anybody
wants to understand this this still
doesn't understand it well at some point
you give up and say I'm gonna figure out
this when I get home but then you never
do because you're too lazy to think
about this I'm saying that right so gee
look at those two pillars prove it you
know hazaragi has to feel love all these
tables with all these bits and you know
what's booked is this stupid verify
you're going to do well it's gonna you
know pick a random edge you know we can
model this then it's going to pick these
inputs with this probability
distribution and then in the fact is
going to read these three bits and check
their product okay and we know that in
the good case you know when this is a
correct labeling or of the corresponding
graph what will happen is he can satisfy
exactly 1 minus Delta fraction of these
constraints and by the soundlessly
mother died well that still here in fact
if you know you should remember the
label covering you know
you have to set parameters to make sure
that there is no assignment in the label
covering that US that's right you want
this to be smaller than the epsilon we
had in the lab recovery thing which
implies that no assignment which sells
by more than half that as long as this
is smaller than the epsilon you remember
we had for the label cover fun yeah yeah
sorry yes thank you
right so if you set the parameters this
way we know that they can't be an
assignment to satisfy more than this
Delta prime fraction which mu and then
we have the pyramids yes why did you
switch to max real in here I can use it
all of this for max 3sat good so yeah so
that's the next thing um well what bike
I could up actually yeah you're saying
just because you're doing this product
here yeah so what what's what's in the
end what condition are we checking you
know this he's reading these three bits
and checking the products it's a max
trillion instance so if you had read
these three bits and instead took the or
of them if we would have had the max
3sat instance and then we would have
wanted to prove this thing with seven
eighths instead I have right yeah so
we'll do that next time
no I guess I'm just wondering why did
you why did you go through why why did
you why the digression to max three
minutes because when we actually gonna
prove the soundness lemma the Sunnis
lemma is a lot easier to prove in this
good it will be easier to prove the the
soundness lemma in this situation but
it's yeah we're going to be gonna do
yeah it's not clear from what I've said
that will appear in Beck's real in yet
but you'll you'll see in tomorrow we're
gonna do max receptor and we know it has
to be okay yeah yeah because otherwise I
mean if it hadn't been needed then we
would have proven this serum right and
that's a false fear because it
try to figure very flavin because that's
the part of the book you haven't shown
you yeah no is it any and you see that
that Delta actually comes in explicitly
here right so this would be zero if you
did have and we'll see where it enters
in the proof of the sunnis lemma but
this is important yeah this is worth a
chocolate yes I have more questions or
comments no more chocolates but you know
we can we can okay let me continue
tomorrow